[Música]
el presidente de Ucrania boludo a Japón
y comenzó a reunirse con los líderes del
g7 mientras el grupo de los siete países
presiona a Rusia para que frene la
guerra e intenta tener un equilibrio con
china Tenemos reporte desde Hiroshima
Rusia advierte que los países
occidentales que le den a Ucrania
aviones de combate f-16 correrán riesgos
colosales el pronunciamiento llegó un
día después de que Washington anunciara
que permitirá el entrenamiento de los
pilotos ucranianos para esta clase de
aeronaves estadounidenses
y las inundaciones en el norte de Italia
ya dejan 14 muertos según la televisión
pública Ray y las autoridades
prolongaron la alerta roja hasta el
domingo en la región de Emilia romaña
ampliamos con nuestra corresponsal
Buenos días Estas son las noticias de
France 24 y yo soy María Clara calle
comenzamos hablando del g7 el presidente
de ucraniano llegó a Hiroshima desde
Arabia Saudita ya tuvo encuentros con la
primera ministra de Italia Georgia
meloni y con el premiere británico
Richie sunak luego se reunió con el
presidente francés Emmanuel majó con
quien discutió la coalición de aviones
que está intentando forjarse lensky para
que occidente envíe aeronaves de combate
escuchemos
hablamos mucho sobre la futura coalición
de jets y Quiero agradecer a ustedes y a
todos los socios por esta decisión sobre
las misiones de entrenamiento compartiré
con ustedes nuestras reuniones de ayer
que han sido muy importantes para
nosotros es muy importante involucrar a
esta fórmula tantos países como sea
posible y estoy feliz de que haya
señales muy positivas
a la coalición de aviones que promueve
el presidente de ucraniano se sumó un
apoyo que puede La balanza durante el
primer día de la reunión del g7 del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
cambió de opinión y aunque aún no habla
de proveer los f-16 el mandatario
sostuvo que permitirá la formación de
pilotos ucranianos boludo y calificó la
decisión de histórica y declaró que
espera discutir los detalles en
Hiroshima veamos el informe
han pasado cinco meses desde que el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
dijera que estaba en contra de enviar
casas f-16 a Ucrania el viernes en la
Cumbre del g7 celebrada en Hiroshima se
retractó y dio oficialmente su
aprobación a las naciones que deseen
entrenar a pilotos ucranianos en los
preciados casas la decisión de Estados
Unidos supone un gran avance para que ha
solicitado infructuosamente a sus
aliados occidentales aviones de alta
tecnología para hacer frente a la
invasión rusa acojo con beneplá la
decisión histórica de los Estados Unidos
y de putus Para apoyar una coalición
internacional de aviones de combate esto
mejorará enormemente nuestro ejército en
el cielo cuento con discutir la
implementación práctica de esta decisión
en la Cumbre del g7 en Hiroshima según
un funcionario de la Casa Blanca Estados
Unidos está abierto a apoyar un esfuerzo
conjunto con sus aliados para entrenar a
los pilotos ucranianos en los aviones
así como a decidir cuándo suministrar
los f-16 cuántos se proporcionarán y
quién los proporcionará Aunque algunas
naciones occidentales como Países Bajos
Bélgica o Noruega poseen varios f-16 de
fabricación estadounidense desde un
punto de vista legal Washington tiene
que aprobar su reexportación la decisión
de Estados Unidos también fue elogiada
por los aliados occidentales el país
está sustituyendo su flota de f-16 por
casas f-35 y ahora podrá avanzar en una
contribución colectiva para formar a
pilotos ucranianos en el pilotaje de los
f-16 Dinamarca hará todo lo posible para
que esta contribución sea prioritaria
sin embargo se tardan meses en entrenar
a un piloto sin hablar de los obstáculos
logísticos por solucionar
varios países occidentales le dieron la
bienvenida a la decisión de Estados
Unidos de permitir el entrenamiento de
pilotos ucranianos en los f-16 y Rusia
lanzó una advertencia el viceministro de
relaciones exteriores Alexander cruzco
señaló que aquellos que suministran
aviones de combate aquí eff correrán
riesgos colosales
Mientras tanto el terreno continúan los
combates los militares de kiev
registraron el bombardeo número 11 sobre
la capital ucraniana de lo que va de
mayo nuestra enviada especial Catalina
Gómez Ángel nos cuenta Más de lo que
ocurrió este sábado
esta madrugada kiev volvió a ser objeto
de un nuevo ataque Ese es el ataque
número 11 desde que comenzó el mes de
mayo y el cuarto de la última semana a
diferencia de otros ataques el de anoche
solamente incluyó drones kamikashi o
chajín Pero la pregunta de la población
en kiev es cuál es realmente el objetivo
de estos ataques para muchos analistas
es desgastar esas defensas aéreas
ucranianas alejarlas del frente de
batalla y también Mostrar un poco de
músculo del lado ruso de Cara a esa
contraofensiva que planean los
ucranianos en las próximas semanas y
también crear pánico dentro de la
población Aunque la vida en quien sigue
adelante Aquí estamos en un conjunto
Residencial donde anoche cayeron partes
de uno de esos drones que fueron
derribados por la defensa antiaérea la
vida sigue relativamente normal si se un
temor la gente cuando Oye las sirenas
vuelve ya no sé si a los refugios
algunos de ellos pero sí se encierran en
los baños son cuartos más protegidos
porque el gran riesgo de estos ataques
que han mostrado que la defensa aérea sí
funciona y puede interceptar estos
misiles o drones es cuando esas partes
caen en medio de la ciudad y muchos de
ellos caen en áreas residenciales como
el que sucedió nuevamente esta mañana se
habla de tres apartamentos aquí que
están averiados aquí vemos gente que
está sacando partes quemadas solamente
cayó en el techo pero en este momento no
pueden habitar este edificio y así se
repite una y otra vez no solamente cada
noche en la ciudad no solamente en kiev
sino en otras partes del país y esto
llega también en un momento donde las
fuerzas rusas avanzan dentro de la
ciudad de bacmut pero las tropas mañana
siguen avanzando A los alrededores de la
ciudad y ellos dicen que a pesar de que
los rusos han traído nuevas fuerzas para
reforzar esas áreas a las alrededores de
bakmut ellos siguen controlandolas Así
que allí sigue la batalla también con
intensidad
fue vetada por Rusia
Moscú declaró como indeseable a la
organización ecologista lo que le
impedirá realizar actividades en pro del
medio ambiente una medida más contra las
ongs y la defensa de los intereses
climáticos que preocupa a la comunidad
internacional
Rusia no volverá a ver acciones como
estas a corto plazo
la ong greenpeace una de las
organizaciones medioambientales más
importantes del mundo fue catalogada
este 19 de mayo como indeseable por el
kremlin según el fiscal general de Rusia
greenpeace intentó interferir en los
asuntos internos del Estado e
involucrarse en la propaganda anti rusa
al pedir sanciones contra Moscú la ong
realizó operaciones en el país para
sensibilizar sobre el cambio climático
luchar contra los incendios forestales y
preservar especies animales pero desde
el comienzo de la invasión rusa a
Ucrania las autoridades han
intensificado la represión contra
quienes critican el kremlin afectando
ahora a greenpeace la etiqueta de
organización indeseable ha sido recibida
por muchos grupos extranjeros desde 2015
en concreto obliga a greenpeace a
detener todas sus actividades en Rusia y
la expone a posibles procesos judiciales
la organización reaccionó enérgicamente
en un comunicado de prensa
la liquidación en Rusia es una medida
Absurda y responsable y destructiva que
nada tiene que ver con la protección de
los intereses del país
las relaciones entre greenpeace y el
poder ruso Siempre han sido tensas en
2013 el gobierno arrestó a miembros de
la ong tras una acción contra una
plataforma petrolera de la empresa
gasprom
en Italia persiste la alerta roja por
las inundaciones en la región de Emilia
romaña en el norte del país y las
autoridades prolongaron la advertencia
también para mañana el número de Muertos
aumentó a 14 luego de que encontraron el
cuerpo sin vida de un hombre de 84 años
en la ciudad de faensa nuestra
corresponsal Natalia Mendoza nos cuenta
más
La pesadilla continúa aquí en Emilia
romaña la región sigue en alerta roja
por inundaciones el número de personas
evacuadas sigue aumentando 15.000
personas han debido a abandonar sus
hogares a causa de estas inundaciones
este sábado
las lluvias han retomado en varias zonas
afectadas para las autoridades italianas
es una verdadera Carrera contra el
tiempo para restaurar las
infraestructuras destruidas los puentes
las carreteras y liberar el acceso a
varios pueblos que todavía hoy
permanecen completamente aislados del
mundo para los habitantes atrapados en
estos lugares los equipos de Socorro
deben llevar alimentos y artículos de
primera necesidad en helicóptero y la
preocupación hoy es la enorme masa de
agua acumulada tierra dentro y que fluye
hacia el mar Esto hace que ahora es en
los pueblos de la costa adriática en
donde se esperan nuevas inundaciones hoy
claramente para los habitantes de aquí
el regreso a la normalidad será y muy
muy complicado
pasamos a Grecia donde habrá elecciones
generales mañana 21 de mayo las
encuestas dicen que al Primer Ministro
saliente
no le alcanzaría para formar una mayoría
los demás partidos no quieren una
coalición con él y cuatro colectivos de
izquierda podrían aliarse para respaldar
Álex Primer Ministro Alexis cipras más
detalles a continuación los habitantes
de lamia en el centro de Grecia se
impacientan dentro de unos minutos
Alexis cifras ex Primer Ministro y líder
de la izquierda radical saldrá su
encuentro y les prometerá soluciones a
la inflación galopante que está
paralizando los hogares promesas en las
que algunos quieren creer sobre todo
cuando al final de mes se presenta
difícil para el bolsillo
recibo mi salario el primero de cada mes
pero del 17 al 18 del mismo mes Busco
las monedas para comprar el pan la leche
o los productos básicos
mi factura de la luz pasó de 140 a 650 a
700 euros de una sola vez eso lo dice
todo en las encuestas el líder de
posición está por detrás del actual
Primer Ministro conservador kiriacos
mitsutakis pero el sistema proporcional
simple puede notar al ganador la mayoría
absoluta por esta razón Alexis cifras
quiere creer en una oportunidad para
volver al poder
ha llegado el momento de un cambio real
la sociedad griega lo necesita y el
pueblo lo quiere creo que daremos Una
gran sorpresa en las elecciones y que mi
partido ganará con mucha diferencia
pero para formar una mayoría en el
parlamento cifras tendrá que unirse con
otros partidos de izquierda incluida la
tolda política de Janis barufakis el
exministro de finanzas de cifras que ha
estado mostrando un fuerte impulso en
las encuestas últimamente y que está
haciendo campaña por un retorno a la
soberanía financiera para Grecia
tomaré mi revancha cuando este país
vuelva a ser viable económicamente
cuando el pueblo salga de la prisión de
la deuda en la que el país quedó
Atrapado en 2015 al aceptar la
austeridad a pesar del rechazo expresado
en referéndum y que me llevó a retirarme
del gobierno
ahora Alexis rechaza una salida de la
eurozona al igual que cualquier
coalición con Janis marufakis de quedar
sin gobierno el país se vería
probablemente obligado a convocar nuevas
elecciones a principios de julio
seis años de prisión es la sentencia que
una jueza del Estado de México le dio a
la joven Roxana Ruiz quien mató a su
agresor para defenderse después de que
el hombre la violara y amenazara con
matarla el presidente de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador prometió un indulto Marina
sardiña tiene la historia
Roxana Ruiz no puede ocultar sus zozobra
desde ese maldito 7 de mayo del 2021 mi
vida
sigo viva Pero
muerta a la vez no la joven mexicana
sufrió una violación cuando apenas tenía
21 años su agresor amenazó con matarla
ella se defendió y en el forcejeo él
murió esa misma noche la policía la
detuvo sin activar los protocolos para
Víctimas de violaciones esta joven madre
soltera pasó nueve meses en prisión
ahora una jueza del Estado de México la
quiere enviar seis años y dos meses a la
cárcel por uso excesivo de legítima
defensa es totalmente injusta la
sentencia de la jueza hacia mi persona
mensaje que manda
las juezas lo que manda el sistema
judicial aquí que
que las mujeres o tenemos de dos o estar
presas o estar muertas no el caso causó
una gran polémica entre los grupos de
derechos que ven injusta y
desproporcionada la sentencia Y es que
México es la nación de América con mayor
número de feminicidios al menos 11 cada
día según datos oficiales el viernes el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
prometió un indulto para Roxana vamos a
buscar la manera
de este ayudar
a la joven y si procede
me refiero a que
se pueda aplicar el indulto pues si hay
sentencias se nos va a facilitar y lo
vamos a hacer solo en 2022 más de 3.750
mujeres fueron Víctimas de feminicidios
en México mientras Roxana espera apelar
la sentencia que le devuelva un anhelo
de vida hasta aquí las noticias sigan
con France 24
[Música]